Spero di mare Bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questa nuova Real Life sta
facendo Reaction ma ci sono le perle da
Reaction tempo fa ho aperto uno scrigno
il vaso di Pandora dei video di quando
ero piccolo Quindi perché non guardare
dei video dove mi cagavo ancora addosso
perché non spiattellare la mia dignità
sul muro Facendoci sputare sopra dei
lama cazzo Uh qua quando abbiamo vinto i
Mondiali raga Sto male sto video qua era
della festa che c'era il mio paese sto
male passiamo alla roba forte raga
Eccoci questo sono io quello è mio padre
che era già stempiato a 30 anni io Meno
male hanno preso da lui io mi immagino
mio padre che mi fa sti video siete
Maranza hanno manzana che ho detto Siete
Paranza con i capelli da Maranza
effettivamente ma c'avevo la culla in
rumeno Drei ballanten Cerca Ciao ciao
Ho fatto la pipì che bravo grazie
[Musica]
Sai è una Challenge una Challenge
spingi uguale Adesso la mia stessa
voglia in palestra Guardate
niente Ci sono arreso era impossibile
Anche qua c'è una perla che andrebbe
ricordata da grande guarda tutto sbavato
sarai l'attore
Ecco grazie Come mi vede Murri sulla mia
macchina perfetto
l'ho già vista sta scena cacchio Questo
è il Porco Rosso aspetta pazzesco raga
Minchia è uguale eh ero contento ma
l'importante è quello adesso ti puoi
comprare un aereo No non è vero ma che
Papillon che Papillon avevo addosso io
non ho mai messo un papillon nella mia
vita
Ah qua Ragazzi per chi i veterani del
canale qua sappiamo tutti di cosa stiamo
parlando vestito di Super Mario E vabbè
fin qua il cosplay è riuscito che bel
Gameplay
io avevo queste costruzioni che si
chiamavano morbidelle che erano tipo dei
LEGO di gomma giganteschi bellissimi Tra
l'altro dove cacchio son finito
stemmorbidente
un gatto Guarda
non è un gatto Lorenzo
Eccola L'Aquila
uguale io che cosa mi insegnavano
all'asilo come fa quell'essere una
sembra una roba non lasciamo perdere
Raga ma che rapper ragazzi iniziamo a
treppare questa è la copertina
dell'album Guarda che che porta mento
faccio un po' di fanservice solo perché
so che aspettate questa parte qua
che in italiano vuol dire
da Happy Days che avevamo tolto Happy
Days hanno messo la trasmissione di
Enrico Papi grazie Enrico Papi per i
traumi Oh Eccola qua perfetto Juventus
Minchia che gol no non è gol Scherzavo
non è gol non è gol peccato peccato
perché non ci credevo ci credevo Eh però
il tiro era buono eh Io l'avrei lo
guarderei al bar Guarda Guardami ad
essere guarda guardalo che controllo
cioè riesco a centrare la porta mezza
volta santo Dio
Ecco qua Eccola lei Denise quella che ha
guidato la macchina nel video della
t-cross Io invece sono così Sono rimasto
così Evidentemente visto che tutti sulla
Mustang non mi ci vedono erano un
costume di tutto rispetto voglio dire
Denise si stava facendo si sta
attaccando addosso qua cioè si vedrà
proprio la faccia Minchia È incredibile
raga Donnie Darko Infatti come l'avrà
presa Denise che mi sono vestito da
Donnie Darko
Ah ragazzi no posto male Questo era il
vestito che avevo nel video che ho fatto
qualche mese fa che ho tolto dal garage
Non so se ve lo ricordate tutti gli
oggetti di giocattoli quando ero piccolo
e avevo provato questo
ma l'avevi chiesto tu a Babbo Natale
Sì avevo chiesto io per favore
no a metà lo apriamo Lorenzo stasera
Exclusive Gameplay Eh questo è Metal
Gear ero anche bravo Beh in questo
momento no Ho preso le scoppole Però
vabbè ma mi sono alzato in piedi perché
è aumentata la difficoltà del Gameplay
giustamente quindi impegno Massimo
Madonna Raga non avete idea di quante
volte io abbia giocato a sto gioco
Madonna ma che è ma che ha investito
come in Grease Ma cos'è ma che taglio è
Ma che dai mamma Ma cosa che che che Ma
cos'è sta cos'è col ciuffo Santo Iddio
non è terribile
Cioè Avevo un gatto un gatto in mano sto
male
abbiamo trovato un gatto Scusatemi
Eccolo
[Musica]
Let's go
la mia madre mi ha lanciato
letteralmente
levati
ho fatto cadere tutto
che fai con lenzuolo di nonna
escaping with lenzuolo
è questo è come mi vede Murri sulla
macchina ragazzi sono contento di aver
portato di nuovo questo contenuto anche
per il fatto che
l'avevamo già visti si vita avevo già
fatto la Reaction Però magari mi ha
messo pezzi nuovi ma sono molto contento
in realtà perché mi mi Diva ogni tanto
mi riguarda anche io perché mi fan
troppo ridere però vabbè Signori io vi
ringrazio di aver visto il video
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace e noi ci vediamo Scusatemi ancora
un po' influenzato si sente dal naso
però vabbè che devo fare raga mi passerà
anche a me e ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Applauso]